a show of support for an army facing
defeat on the battlefield
they chant the name of Junta leader
Captain Ibrahim tarare who has lost
control of almost half of the country to
arm groups linked to Al-Qaeda and isil
despite the military setbacks
these demonstrators believe trauri is
bringing sovereignty back to Burkina
Faso after he cut military cooperation
with France the former colonial power
the president has shown us that he has
what it takes to govern the country he
showed us by chasing France out of the
country
chasing armed groups out of the country
is proving more difficult than expected
without the military support of France
or cooperation from the United States
troire is looking at new Partnerships on
Thursday he announced Russia has become
a key strategic Ally but denied the
presence of Russian mercenaries
there are many countries that have
refused to sell his equipment refused
outright others have told us that they
don't sell lethal equipment or expected
to fight the enemy with rocks so we've
turned to other countries to buy arms
in April the Junta announced a mass
mobilization calling on anyone fit and
above the age of 18 to take up arms and
fight for the nation but human rights
organizations say badly trained soldiers
are perpetrating atrocities
156 civilians were killed by men in
uniform last month the Army deny their
involvement Civil Society groups fear
these crimes are going unpunished
despite these scenes on Saturday many
people are growing increasingly
frustrated with a military setbacks
I think these protests are an attempt to
hide defeats we haven't seen the Army
reconquer territory and more and more
Villages are being displaced by armed
groups and terrorists
these demonstrations are seen as an
attempt to lift the morale of a Nation
where two million people are displaced
and thousands have been killed in what
seems an Unstoppable and unwinnable War
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera